And I think in order to,
to make a break out format,
you really need to be
extremely original and sort of break
the barriers of a lot of things
that have been done before.
Assaf Gil, thank you
for joining me on my show.
How are you?
Not too bad.
Thanks very much.
You know, I'm not used
to seeing your face.
I'm used to seeing
the title of your company at the end
of pretty much every show
that I enjoy watching on TV.
So, it's definitely an interesting
experience now watching you in person.
But Assaf,
Gil, obviously is the last name.
But what's really,
I think, fascinating to me is that
you really are a key figure
in the entertainment industry in Israel.
And I think that's
what I'm especially curious to hear about
in these next 20 minutes,
is some of the thought process that goes
behind creating entertainment,
bringing that to reality and really
productizing it for the
market here in Israel.
So, Assaf, please take it away
and tell me a little bit
about your journey.
And how do you even get started
with even wanting to be on television?
If I'm correct, I would say Ladim
was one of the first appearances.
Yes.
Well, I actually,
I wasn't born a producer.
I started out as an actor.
I trained in London
for four years.
And then when coming back to Israel,
I acted in theater
and a business television here.
After which, I sort of decided that
it wasn't it for me,
which I'm really happy about
that decision, because unlike
other would-be actors or people who
wanted it and never achieved it,
I was really through
with my wish to be an actor.
So, once that happened to me,
I was really dedicated to producing.
And I think one of the key issues
in my career at least, was the fact that
the success, or as you mentioned,
the fact that I'm almost everywhere
on television in Israel as a producer,
didn't come to me very quickly.
I think that for about 15 years,
I was producing sort of small shows,
getting, you know, learning
quite a lot through
the process of working.
And only at the tender
age of 43, I think,
I really hit the prime time
in commercial television in Israel,
which really was a big
breakthrough for me
and from the word goal.
Since I was on prime time,
i was very fortunate to have
a huge success in almost
every show I produced.
Assaf, I have to pick your brain
about this whole industry
because coming from the tech scene,
you know,
I think the equivalent to you saying
reaching prime time is
sort of reaching like an exit
for a startup sort or going public.
That's sort of like the,
I guess, the analogy.
But talk to me a little bit about
how this industry is built
and what are some
of the biggest challenges
that it takes for a producer
to reach at the tender age of 43,
to reach that prime time experience?
Well, you know, television in Israel
is a small marketplace.
And it's extremely competitive
because there's a large number of
production companies
with a limited amount of networks.
So, that makes it very tough.
Actually, throughout the years,
i don't think it became any easier.
It only it feels like sort of a big war
going through the years.
And first and foremost,
I must say that
the battle is for great shows,
great ideas, formats,
if they are sort of purchase for Israel,
IP that is purchased
to be produced locally
from successful shows elsewhere.
And also, here and there
when we do have the chance
to create our own
original shows and IP.
Right. That makes a lot of sense.
And talk to me
a little bit about what is a format?
So, I'm guessing that it's some structure
to a show that might repeat itself,
might be able to then scale
also to other places.
But just talk to me a little bit,
because you have both
the Gil Production side and Gil Formats.
Right?
Which are, they're
like siblings entities.
But talk to me about each one separately
and how they work together
here in the Israeli marketplace.
Sure.
So, basically,
the formats I'm talking about
or the formats that we're dealing with
are non scripted formats.
So, we're not talking about
scripted shows.
We're talking about
non-scripted television.
And the format is basically
a very comprehensive concept,
which is very well defined.
And, you know, impossible to imitate,
if you like, without going into lawsuits.
And it's always starting out as an idea
and then being developed further
and further, sometimes,
through violent episodes,
sometimes it's being commissioned.
And Gil Productions is really
a pure production entity that
currently in the Israeli marketplace,
we're producing six really huge shows
for all networks here.
And Gil Formats was
established as a company in 2015
because we came to realize that
we have a lot of our own original stuff
that we would like to distribute and
sell outside of Israel.
And we made some very nice successes
through this IP, this original IP.
Some of it
was produced initially in Israel
and then exported.
And some was actually first,
produced first outside of Israel.
So, that was even more exciting.
So, I mean, let's say that I'm a young,
a young media entrepreneur
and I have an idea for a show
that is called Come Eat with Me.
By the way, I love that show.
And I want to put it on.
Come down with me.
I want to actually start this up as
a real proper show.
What are some of the big milestones
that I'll have to go through
as a media entrepreneur
or is coming in with this format,
whether I pitch it
to Gil Formats or somebody else,
what are some of the steps
that I'll have to go through?
I think that unlike, perhaps tech
ideas that might be
sometimes easier to launch, I find,
because I'm getting pitched
on an average of two
formats at least a day,
so it's hundreds per year.
And I must say that
most of them are not that good because,
You're like a venture capital investor.
In a way, I am. Yes.
I think that some of the ideas are very,
you know,
they are very much
similar to other things
that are on air with slight differences
that don't really make
that much of a difference.
And I think in order to make
a break out format, you really need to be
extremely original and sort of break
the barriers of a lot of things
that have been done before.
On the other hand, I think that some
of the ideas I'm being pitched with
are okay, great, actually on paper,
but once you go into the nitty gritty
of producing them,
of making them a television show,
most people don't really understand
the barriers of television or how
a television show is produced.
And that's why some of the ideas are
purely hypothetical, because
they cannot get to a practical
you know,
they cannot really be achieved.
So, it's a really tough process.
But if you do have an original
successful format, it can potentially
bring you lots of money and lots of,
you know, it could be a big springboard
if you do manage to create something
original that could be successful.
Right. Talk to me a little bit
about reality television.
That's also a big part of what you do.
Why do I love reality TV so much?
Why do I find myself able to sit through
watching an entire season
of a reality show without stopping?
I think that's maybe the only thing
I can do without stopping for hours.
Why is that?
I think that, you know,
what always works on television
is a story and it's always
a personal story and there's always need,
there's a need for some sort of stake
of what the people are going through.
There's a challenge,
there's something out of the ordinary.
Some of the reality shows that we all know
when wanting to achieve the
you know, this challenge,
for instance, in Survivor,
they could send people to a remote island
to starve them and put them through
impossible challenges just to get
the personal story, the personal truth.
Some other shows,
which I've been also fortunate to produce
there the challenge is that
naturally, for instance, one of the
successful show
I produced a few years ago
in Israel was called Baby Boom.
In the original UK version,
it's called One Born Every Minute.
And what we did was just document
births in a hospital ward.
And it was extremely emotional
and dramatic,
simply just by putting a camera there.
Because the challenge was there,
we didn't need to create it.
Some reality shows have to manipulate
and create the challenge and the drama,
whereas some of the other shows,
the drama is sort of inherent
in the process.
I prefer the other type of shows
because I think that, nowadays,
viewers are very critical.
They can see the manipulations.
And I think that as long as the person
involved, the person on television
is going through something real,
it's better.
And I think most of my shows
were focus on that.
I think that's fascinating
and I have to say that I agree.
I enjoy watching both
the very early seasons of these shows,
but I also enjoy watching
the later season of these shows
and the new reality shows like Baby Boom,
which I also love.
And you can tell the difference.
You can tell the difference
in authenticity.
And you can tell when that person
is going through an emotional experience
that is very relevant
that you can actually connect with.
But Assaf, tell me a little bit about,
about the trajectory
of where we're headed
with television and reality TV also.
So, what have been
some of the major changes
aside from the authenticity
in the past decade or so?
And where are we headed
towards in the future?
Well, you know, everyone is talking about
the problem of linear television
and is it going to still be relevant.
I think it is.
Because I think
the challenge of current
day television is
television really needs
to reinvent itself
as a must see platform.
You can watch Netflix,
you can binge shows and obviously
have lots of fun with it.
But I think the challenge of linear
television is to be able to
offer viewers something
that they really need to see,
they won't be able to see
on the SVOD platforms.
And I think, I do see
a long future of television ahead of us.
You know, my recent show in Israel
which is a huge success everywhere,
The Messenger, is something like that
because it is something
that has a great deal
of engagement with viewers.
People need to be involved.
They want to be involved.
It's the talk the next day, everywhere.
And it's the type of show which
brings back the value of television.
And I think that's part
of the things I like to do,
because I do like to produce things
which are a bit of an adventure,
a bit of something refreshing,
something different.
And I think,
that was one of the reasons
why I, you know,
took an option on this format very early
before it launch in the US
and some other format as well.
When I felt that there is something
that is different, there is an adventure
in having this on television.
And I think that's one of the key issues.
Not doing more of the same,
doing things which are
completely different.
Assaf, I think that's just incredible.
Tell me a little bit about yourself.
Why are you so excited about
starting new shows
and continuing to innovate?
You mentioned that you started off really
getting into the bits and pieces
and the exciting parts at 43.
But why today?
Why do you still enjoy getting pitched
at least two ideas per day and then
continuing to do new formats?
You know, I love what I do.
It's really not something that
when I wake up in the morning,
I don't have any qualms
about what I'm doing.
I don't have other dreams.
It's not like I wish I would have,
I would do something else.
It never, never happened to me.
I really am totally enchanted
with what I'm doing.
And I love to create.
And I think part of the
magic of creating for television
is being able to
use a lot of your senses
and both intellect and emotions.
But I would say
first and foremost, intuition.
I think television for me, at least,
television works a lot on intuition.
And that's why I love this field.
Because you're going through
a lot of unknowns.
You're going through
a lot of black holes.
You're not sure what's going to happen
when you know,
how you're going to come out
of the other side.
And that's part
of the magic of television.
And that's why it's so exciting.
And it always has been.
What's been the greatest challenge
that you had to overcome
in doing the amazing work
that you're doing right now?
Well, the biggest challenges
are me pitching to other people,
of course.
So, you're talking about
as if I'm a VC being pitched to,
but I'm also
pitching to the networks in Israel,
I'm pitching to networks abroad,
to production companies abroad.
That's always a big challenge.
Because normally,
you're in a position
when you're pitching to people
who are very anxious
about making bold moves
and taking risks.
And if you are being adventurous,
which is what I like to do,
it's always
a challenge pitching to people
who are almost prone to taking risks,
risk-verse people.
And that's, I would say,
my biggest challenge.
I love that.
And if you look over,
you know, the incredible career
that you've had, and I have to,
first of all,
I have to say thank you,
because I think that, you know,
besides from being an innovator
and creating all these things,
you really you impacted so many lives.
And you know, I can still recall it,
and I will never forget
those Saturday nights
when I would sit with my family,
everybody together
huddle in front of the screen
because we're excited about
somebody's journey,
whether it's through Baby Boom
or another reality TV.
I think it brings people together.
I think it creates excitement
and creates an internal excitement
for every person watching it.
And I think that allowing us
to experience these emotions is a gift.
And so, I want to thank you
for giving us that gift.
And also, thank you for being
so generous with your time
and coming here.
Assaf, before we leave, I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Well, I'll pick up on a lot of things
I said here, I would probably say,
it's a bit embarrassing,
but I would probably say that
I'm intuitive, I'm experienced because
it took me some time before I made a move
and when successful.
And I'm adventurous.
These are the three things
I can say about me.
I love it.
Assaf, thank you so, so much.
This was really, really wonderful.
And thank you very much.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Michael.